when you were starting out in stand-up
comedy and i'm talking about you guys
are real young you're real green you
hadn't done a lot of it
and you saw guys like chris rock who was
starting out at the same time yeah and
like jon stewart was another guy that
you would say
tell me the truth were they bad at stand
up now does everyone start out bad back
then when we would do the comic strip
yep we used to go on at the comic strip
and catch a rising star
uh
we none of us were great yet
and i don't know if any you know i don't
say i'm great now i'm i'm whatever
you guys were green you were starting
young but the thing i think all of us
had in common were was we were we didn't
we weren't afraid of not doing well we
wouldn't go on stage and and it didn't
go over well and it didn't rattle us
enough to want to quit you so you saying
that in stand-up comedy when you start
the best asset you could have is that if
you're going to get rattled that means
you're probably going to leave because
it means you're getting too affected
maybe bombing maybe i mean
you you do want to do as when the times
when it would go well it was exciting
and uh if you had five good minutes and
and you had a big set and that was that
was a great feeling but
it was the the other ones uh the guys
you loved were guys who would [ __ ] do
their stuff
they would stay true to who they were
and the crowd hated them and they just
continued plowing through see i wish i
could hear tapes of like you
chris rock and and jon stewart guys like
that at the beginning
yeah because everyone always assumes
that everyone is like self-realized like
uh you know people say oh you know
you're really good on the radio i go you
should hear what i sounded like when i
started i was like the i was the worst
radio announcer ever funny man yeah i
mean i
i always thought you were confident says
i've been listening to you since i'm you
know young but but uh i think out of
rock and jon stewart it took me the
longest to figure out uh what the hell i
was doing up there i was i was in and
out of different personalities on stage
i remember rock was was always rock
right since since i've
met him when we were like 18 and and he
was always pretty much had his his
delivery was consistent it was
consistent he might not have had the
material but he had yeah yeah and his
material was actually pretty uh
unbelievable back then also but he said
[ __ ] that would
baffle people and and he was i remember
i don't even know who it was but when we
were really young i remember rock
getting off stage and another comedian a
young guy who who was goes oh man i
gotta go after that i feel like i'm so
[ __ ] useless after what he said i'm
all my [ __ ] so stupid like he made
people self-conscious of what he was
yeah he was just ahead of everybody oh i
would think that's the worst i know i
used to watch kevin meaney yeah kevin
meaney used to go on at the catcherizing
star and it was just bananas how hard he
would kill and people it was you know
like 15 20 minutes of destruction
and then you just you just knew you
couldn't go after that and that people
would not even know you were on stage
and why do you think you stayed in it
like when you see a guy like meaney and
you see like chris rocks oh yeah well
he's got his persona i can't even figure
out what my personality is
what keeps you in the game it seems oh
man i i was so crazy when i was young i
just thought yeah i'm going to be huge
i'm some psychotic guy my brother my
brother sent me on my way
when we were growing up he said yeah
it was i was applying for college and he
and i said what should i do and he said
you should be uh an actor i said oh okay
you should be comedian he goes you're as
funny as eddie murphy and i went oh okay
and that was it and that's it
and you believed it yeah yeah i think i
told my friends i was gonna be huge
growing up and i didn't i didn't like
when i went on my way i moved from new
hampshire to new york and i think i told
him yeah i'm gonna be become a huge
comedian yeah and i think that had
something to do with not wanting to quit
ever that i was like i already told
those guys i'm gonna be huge i've got to
get this [ __ ] done i can't go home